[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN GABRIELI: Our
laboratory is really
interested in understanding
how children's minds
and brains grow and develop.
The field has largely used this
term, the 30 million word gap.
And that comes out of research,
where researchers recorded
home conversations between
parents and children
of various levels of family
income and education.
And they estimated,
or they calculated,
that a child who arrives at
the beginning of school, who
comes from high income,
high education family
has heard 30 million
more words spoken to him
or her than a child who comes
from a family where there's
lesser education
and lesser income.
RACHEL ROMEO: So the question is
why and what do we do about it.
We know that the
language exposure
is contributing to the
children's language abilities.
But what is the
mechanism underlying
this input-output relationship?
How is the language
exposure translating
into a language gap?
JOHN GABRIELI: And
the second thing
we were very interested in is,
although we know that this word
gap is associated
with family income,
how close is that relationship.
So we had to go look for
lots of parents with kids
from a broad range and
diverse backgrounds,
in terms of income
and education at home,
and ask them to wear
a device at home
so we could record
the number of words
that were spoken between
parents and children,
as well as a number of
conversational turns.
RACHEL ROMEO: We had a small
fleet of audio recorders
that children would actually
wear in a shirt pocket.
And they would wear
these from the time
they woke up to the time
they went to bed at night.
And then we would use speech
recognition algorithms
to determine how much
speech they had been hearing
and how much speech they had
been producing themselves,
and then how many
back and forth turns
they'd been taking with other
conversational partners.
JOHN GABRIELI: And then
the children came in,
and this was the exotic
part of the study.
They went into an MRI scanner.
And we recorded their brains as
they heard little stories that
were spoken to them
while their brains were
being monitored through
functional magnetic resonance
imaging.
RACHEL ROMEO: Neuroimaging
was pretty labor intensive,
as well.
Working with children
as young as four,
it's very difficult to
do MRI scans with them.
Because they have to lie
perfectly still so that we
can get nice, clear images.
So I'm sitting next
to our mock scanner.
It's a wooden replica of
what the MRI scanner actually
looks like.
And if they move too much,
the motion sensitive camera
will cut off their video.
So it's kind of a conditioned
training for these children
to teach themselves to lie still
while they're doing the imaging
sessions.
After we finished
collecting all of the data,
we were excited to look at how
the home language experience
related to the brain functions.
And what we were
surprised to find
is that the number
of adult words
didn't seem to matter at
all for the brain function.
What mattered was the number
of conversational turns.
JOHN GABRIELI: The part of the
brain that showed the biggest
difference, in relation to the
conversational turns at home
is one of the two major
language areas of the brain that
is called Broca's area.
And what we saw was that
the more these children had
conversational turns at
home, the more this area
was engaged as they heard
stories spoken to them while we
were imaging their brains.
The second thing we were
surprised by a little bit
was that it didn't matter
the education or income
level of the family.
What mattered was how
often these conversations
turned back and forth.
RACHEL ROMEO: So we're
taking these results
as a social optimism of sorts.
Because socioeconomic
status, or SES,
is largely difficult to change.
But a conversation
with your child
is something much more
simple, much more malleable.
JOHN GABRIELI: So
our next goal is
to work on
interventions that will
help families have more of these
conversations back and forth.
Can we not only describe
this relationship,
but can we foster and enhance it
so more parents are comfortable
and supported in
having these kinds
of critical conversational
turns with their children.
[MUSIC PLAYING]